i think this is a good place to ask
we asked the what is money question
what is bitcoin
that's a question as complicated as what
is money
i think if you get a general
understanding of money
from a number of angles
that we could say bitcoin is the most
superior monetary technology that has
ever
existed so one of the most
superior implementation of the ideas of
money that you talked about you talked
about money as speech he talked about
money is an idea
we talked about money as sovereignty
yeah
so we're attaching the concept of money
to your point
to whatever tool best satisfies
those properties of money or best
renders those services we need for money
and as you said you're using the word
tool and technology interchangeably yes
yes and another thing to think about
here is that
we think often in terms of goods or
services
but actually everything is a service
so it's not the physical properties of
this pen that i find valuable
it's the services that it renders to me
that i want to write a letter
this gives this serves me by allowing me
to lay ink on
paper and communicate information so
value humans attach value as we alluded
to earlier
two services not goods so the properties
or the services that money renders that
human beings value
are those five properties visibility
durability recognizability portability
scarcity metals best satisfied
those services historically but bitcoin
as the most superior monetary technology
in human history
essentially perfects them it's as close
to perfection as we've ever been
so in terms of divisibility each bitcoin
can be broken down into 100 million
subunits called a satoshi
um it could if that divisibility were
ever a problem
which actually um there was a question
that came up recently if you divide the
world population
by the total supply of bitcoin you end
up at like 0.3 bitcoin
per person call it uh 300 000 satoshis
per person
what if that was not enough to
facilitate economic activity
and the answer to that is bitcoin can
soft fork into further divisibility so
if bitcoin ate
all the money in the world and the
average
bitcoiner wealth would say 300 000
satoshi's each but that wasn't
uh divisible enough maybe to buy coffee
and do all these day-to-day transactions
what would happen well we would increase
divisibility so bitcoin's perfected the
visibility the divisibility of money
lets us transact across scales right we
can buy coffee or we can buy a house
durability is an interesting one so
clearly something like gold is very
durable it's resistant to
degradation over time bitcoin is just
pure information
but it's stored in a distributed format
so information stored in a distributed
fashion
tends to be virtually infinitely durable
uh the example i like to give here is
something like the bible
the bible is just distributed
information it's stored
everywhere and nowhere so to speak and
for that reason it has outlasted empires
and bitcoin's similar right you can't
make changes to it unilaterally
but to uh make explicit the the ways in
which it is not durable
is the fact that it relies on computing
infrastructure
like it uh it needs computers so if you
were to destroy all the computers in the
world
yes it needs mechanisms
that store and transfer information
that's right
and so you could attack it i mean you
could attack gold in the same kind of
way as opposed to the physics
but it's probably easier to destroy all
the computers in the world than it is
destroy all the gold in the world maybe
not
i don't know anyway yeah yeah you're
right
uh maybe i'm not sure which one would be
harder to destroy
but the other thing is there's a dynamic
incentive so every time you just you
destroy bitcoin miners
you're creating incentives for anyone
else with access to electricity to mine
right because you're making the
algorithm easier yeah so the
destruction is difficult because of the
decentralized nature of the whole thing
and the difficulty adjustment
yeah so you're gonna have to use nuclear
weapons and and
cover the whole globe but anyway yeah
and by then we've got much bigger
problems than money right
[Laughter]
that's right so okay so that's
durability so portability
bitcoin is pure information it can move
at the speed of light can't get much
faster than that
uh recognizability refers to
the ability to verify the veracity of
the money or its authenticity
so you can actually when we used to
transact gold
there were time honored techniques for
verifying that it was gold
and not gold-plated lead for instance
this is where we get the term sound
money
a gold coin made a very particular sound
when dropped from a certain height
you know you've seen people buying coins
these are all techniques for testing
uh the authenticity of gold and with
bitcoin
we have something unique in that if
you're running a full node you can
verify
that the bitcoin is bitcoin right it
cannot be
tampered with it cannot be faked and in
addition to that
as a node operator you can audit the
total supply of bitcoin at any time
which is unlike any money in history so
you know with full certainty if you're
holding
1000 bitcoin you have 1 000 out of a
possible 21 million
forever you have a guaranteed fraction
of the total supply
yeah so a full node contains information
about every transaction that's ever been
has so you can figure out
yeah i mean that's right all the truth
of the
this money is all right there yeah it's
like a fractal constituent of the whole
network right
the whole bitcoin blockchain is
comprising a node too
not not the proof of work piece but the
entire transaction history
um and so that's unique as well and
that's what makes bitcoin
the ultimate store value is that you
know with certainty what the total
supply is
and will ever be and you know that your
share
of that supply is fixed it cannot change
it can only improve actually if someone
loses
you know if the satoshi stash is truly
gone forever the million bitcoin
never moves then we're talking about a
thousand bitcoin out of 20 million
instead
and so on and so forth there's more peop
as more people lose access to their
bitcoin
they're basically making a contribution
to everyone else it's anti-dilutive
and there's certain properties of
bitcoin that are sort of a little bit
more into the details
that ensure that the the full nodes
like the size of all the transactions
that ever happened
at least currently can be stored in a
single computer for example so it's not
it doesn't blow up too quickly
that's right but you know there's
arguments that that's not necessary
you can make arguments for that to be a
very nice property but you can also say
that there's like drawbacks to it that's
hence the the the block size debates and
all those kinds of things
yeah that was the bitcoin cash civil war
right was that particular piece
um yeah and you know ostensibly they
were saying oh we need more transaction
throughput
to buy more coffee and do more
transactions but
what they're actually doing was
increasing the size
uh um computing power necessary to run a
full node which would
which it would have theoretically
compromised decentralization
so yeah but it would in theory this is
you know in theory it would allow you to
have
much more transactions that's right but
the the drawback it would
because of the no longer it can be
stored in a single computer
personal computer then it uh naturally
leads to the centralization
same kind of thing we see with gold
which would have compromised its
survivability all right
so um i said what else is that the last
one which
leads straight into this one actually is
the most important one of money which is
scarcity
and that you need to know the supply
is fixed and safeguarded from
counterfeiting
[Music]
and inflation which counterfeiting and
inflation are the same thing by the way
counterfeiting is criminalized inflation
inflation is legalized counterfeiting so
central banks today when they say
they're printing money they're not
they're counterfeiting currency
um that's a very important part and
bitcoin
as i've argued in some of my riding is
more than just an invention
it's actually the discovery of absolute
scarcity
and that we have unveiled a property of
money
that we will only discover once um
and it's got really major ramifications
for the world at large so with gold
for instance as we've covered it became
money because it was the most relatively
scarce monetary metal right its supply
was hardest to
increase over time however if we could
somehow flip a switch today and make
everyone
in the world go out and start mining
gold we could increase the supply much
more quickly we could you know it's
historic inflation rates about two
percent
we could double that pretty quickly
bitcoin with bitcoin it is not possible
so no matter how much effort and energy
and capital
uh and operational expenditure we pour
into the mining network
we cannot deviate from its fixed and
diminishing supply curve
from between now and the last bitcoin
being mined in 2140
because of the difficulty adjustment
it's constantly it's adapting to human
action
actually so the harder we pursue it the
more that it recedes
and then the less we pursue it the more
available it makes itself
and this is it's a
real major breakthrough because it's the
closest thing
to perfect information we've ever had in
an economy
and perfect information is this it's a
theoretical but unattainable
state of the market where all market
actors have all the relevant information
uh about everything so that they can
compete as efficiently as possible
and in this state in a state of pure
information we have i'm sorry perfect
information we have perfect competition
and in perfect competition we maximize
wealth generation
so we're competing uh as freely as
possible
from coercive and violent impediments
and so i think bitcoin in that sense
is going to pull the world closer to
a state a per of perfect competition
than we've ever been before
which would increase wealth degeneration
to an extent we've never seen before
you